supongamos que tenemos una partícula que
está viajando en una dimensión y su
posición en función del tiempo está dada
por t cubica + 2 sobre t cuadrada
lo que quiero que hagas es que le pongas
pausa el vídeo y calcule es cuál es la
aceleración promedio la aceleración
promedio sobre el intervalo cerrado
desde que t es igual a 1 hasta que t es
igual a 2 cuál es el valor de esto
supongo que ya lo intentaste y lo
primero que pudiste notar es que estamos
tomando el promedio una función que no
conocemos conocemos la función de
posición pero no conocemos la función
que nos da la aceleración
afortunadamente sabemos que la
aceleración es la derivada con respecto
al tiempo de la velocidad mientras que
la velocidad es la derivada con respecto
al tiempo de la posición así es que para
obtener la aceleración derivamos dos
veces esta función para posteriormente
obtener el promedio sobre el intervalo
hagamos eso derivamos dos veces esta
función pero antes voy a reescribir esto
de tal manera que sea más fácil derivar
lo
si dividimos cada uno de estos términos
entre t cuadrada vamos a obtener que
cubica sobre t cuadrada es igual a t 2
sobre t cuadrada que podemos escribir
como dos por t a la menos 2 y ahora
calculamos la derivada así es que vd t
la velocidad en función del tiempo es
igual es la derivada de esto con
respecto al tiempo esto va a ser la
derivada de t con respecto a t que es
uno más
veamos menos 2 por 2 es igual a menos 4
que multiplica a t elevada a la menos
dos menos uno que multiplica t elevada a
la menos tres bien ahora para encontrar
la aceleración como función del tiempo
simplemente derivamos esto con respecto
al tiempo así es que la aceleración como
función del tiempo es igual a déjame
usar mejor otro color para mantener ese
verde para la aceleración promedio
entonces la aceleración como función del
tiempo es igual vamos a derivar esta
función la derivada de una constante es
igual a cero pues la función no cambia y
la derivada de esto es menos 3 x menos
12 que multiplica a t elevada a la menos
tres menos 1 t elevada a la menos 4 y
ahora para encontrar la aceleración
promedio la aceleración promedio
básicamente tenemos que calcular la
integral definida de esta función sobre
el intervalo y dividirla entre el tamaño
del intervalo así es que esto es igual a
dividimos entre la longitud del
intervalo que es uno sobre dos menos uno
que es uno que multiplica a la integral
definida desde uno hasta dos de la
función de aceleración que es 12 por t
elevado a la menos 4
dt y esto cuánto nos da bien de nueva
cuenta esto es uno sobre uno simplemente
uno y ahora tomamos la anti derivada de
esto la cual nos da bien vamos a ponerla
directamente aquí esto es igual entonces
t elevado a la sumamos un al exponente
menos 41 es sería de al menos 3 por 2 se
dividió entre menos 3 y esto es igual
ignorando constantes por supuesto a
menos 4 que multiplica a t a la menos 3
y ya teníamos este resultado aquí claro
aquí teníamos una constante pero al
tomar la integral definida esas
constantes se van a cancelar al restar
el límite superior del inferior se van a
cancelar así es que la anti derivada de
12 por t a la menos 4 es sumando 1 al
exponente nos da t a la menos 3 que
multiplica a 12 entre menos 3 que es
menos cuatro menos cuatro por t al menos
tres que tenemos que evaluar en el
límite superior inferior en dos y en uno
y esto es igual a evaluamos la función
en el límite superior del intervalo que
sería menos 4 que multiplica a 2 elevado
a la menos 3 menos 4 que multiplica a 2
elevado a la menos 3 1 sobre 81 octavo
ya eso le vamos a restar el valor de la
función en el límite inferior lo cual es
igual
4 x 1 elevado al menos 3 que es 1 así es
que tenemos que restarle menos 4 y esto
a cuánto nos va a dar igual esto es
igual al menos 4 entre 8 esto es igual a
menos un medio menos 4 por un octavo es
igual a menos un medio ya eso le
restamos menos 4 es decir más 4
finalmente 4 menos un medio es igual a
tres enteros un medio o si lo queremos
escribir como una fracción impropia esto
es igual a 7 medios así es que el valor
de la aceleración promedio sobre el
intervalo es igual a 7 medios si la
posición está dada en metros y el tiempo
en segundos la aceleración promedio
sería siete medios metros por segundo al
cuadrado aceleración promedio entre el
tiempo igual a un segundo y el tiempo
igual a dos segundos